The burden of responsibility in a relationship
is always gonna go from the parent to the child,
not the child to the parent.
So nothing bothers me more than when a parent says,
well, what about my feelings?
What about their consideration for me?
When talking about a conflict between a parent and a child,
even if that child is an adult.
So the big red flag there
is that they probably were never considered important
or their feelings hurt when they were kids,
and now they're expecting that
and feel entitled to that from their children.
And then they'll blame it on something of like,
well, they're adults now.
But in my opinion, that does nothing
except maybe
say that that person is adult enough
to know how to handle conflict resolution.
The power dynamics,
and the burden of responsibility always flows downward.
Just because your feelings were not prioritized by your parents
does not mean
that your children are responsible for prioritizing yours.
Kids are not a fix it for a bad childhood.